[Music]
this morning on the dish restaurateur
Karl Silva since Kate born and raised in
New Hampshire he first headed to the
south to attend college at Clemson
University there he studied architecture
but soon realized his true passion was
hospitality in the mid-90s he took a
leap of faith and opened his first
restaurant the eight five eight in
Greenville South Carolina but he clearly
had a Midas touch that one venue
launched his table 301 Restaurant Group
now with ten signature restaurants
covering a wide range of cuisines from
Sobeys new south to passerelle French
bistro to Gianna's modern Italian and
even a juice bar and a food truck and
Carl so Basinski good morning welcome to
the dish tell us about this great table
good morning thanks for having me
so we're gonna eat some enjoy some
staples of the South we start off with
our crab cakes we have some Creole
creamed corn from New Orleans a little
New Orleans touch will come over to our
shrimp and grits with our Port Royal Low
Country shrimp and Anson Mills grits
Glen Roberts gets all the credit for
what he's done it Anson Mills and
reviving some heirloom seeds and and
products back from the colonial and
antebellum era fried green tomatoes you
can't go wrong with I love these and at
the restaurant we individually put a
dollop of southern staple pimento cheese
in between a pimento cheese drizzle over
the top great story about our cheddar
garlic biscuits opening night of the
restaurant we waiter came up and said
we've got the butter cut what do we do
with it and what are we gonna serve the
bread on and it was like oops we don't
have bread for this restaurant so
quickly chef went back into the
restaurant some flour some shortening
cheddar garlic and lo and behold we have
20 years later still serving those and
they're really good ended up with our
white chocolate banana cream pie and of
course mm-hmm
no meal is complete without my cocktail
so this is made with our makers mark
private select oh nice we went to
maker's mark a couple years ago and
blended this special select for the
restaurant
my whistle and I understand you may have
we're very grateful is what we are is
that coming up there I would suggest
while you're there after a morning of
tasting and blending take take lunch to
soak it all in and then come back and
finalize us explain to us because you
are a northeastern boy from New England
how did you end up in the south and
explained to us how you actually studied
something very different than
Hospitality sure so I thought I wanted
to be an architect went to Clemson
University studied architecture and
started waiting tables as a student and
just fell in love with this industry
fell in love with hospitality food
taking care of people but you took a big
risk because you went you were 27 when
you opened your first restaurant what
was a shoe store in downtown Greenville
that's right I just I saw I think the
planning and the architectural
background helped me to visualize what
could be and trusting in the founding
fathers of Greenville and seeing that
there was a lot of emphasis on growing
Greenville and the people left at you
they did they went they laughed all the
way up the street where we started our
first dress because now was laughing
yeah right the beauty scene was pretty
singular in South Carolina I remember so
how did you figure out oh I'm gonna
start a restaurant I have a specific way
I'm gonna do it and service is key yeah
so hospitality has always been our
number one you can go get a great meal a
lot of places but if you put the food
the service and the atmosphere and the
ambiance together and take care of
people and and that taking care of
people is something I learned from Danny
Meyer and his enlightened hospitality
philosophy and we've tried to carry that
on in our restaurants you were also
smart enough I mean you went out and you
got you've got farmers to bring up into
the city of creating a farmers market to
help lure people downtown we did that
was one of the City Hall's directives
and so we went out and got farmers to
come on board and and they started out
and then one of our greatest stories is
one of our old cooks turned into a
farmer and started doing a loom tomatoes
and he is still very successful for this
day that's really impacting the culture
of the city tell us a little bit about
your untraditional way of passing on
your restaurants your employees because
that I thought was incredible thank you
I had a I had a big birthday a year ago
and so it's it causes you to start to
evaluate things and I started looking at
an exit strategy and a legacy yeah and
we've had some wonderful
people work with us and one of the
things that I want to do is help develop
the next series of entrepreneurs and so
folks that work hard and want to own
their own restaurants we're giving them
a chance to do that now it's really
great if you could sign the dish and
explain to us if there was any one that
you would like to have this meal with
who would it be
well you mentioned New England earlier
and oh the goat the six-time be honored
to have dinner with us and for more on
Carl in the dish head to our website as
cBS This Morning Calm